the Bible is a series of books written
edited and assembled over thousands of
years
it contains the
most influential stories of mankind
knowledge of these stories is essential
to a deep understanding of Western
culture which is in turn vital to proper
psychological health as human beings our
cultural animals and to societal
stability these stories are neither
history as we commonly conceived it nor
empirical science instead their
investigations into the structure of
being itself and calls to action within
that being they have deep psychological
significance hi everyone I just wanted
to make a quick video to remind everyone
or let everybody who's watching know
that I'm starting my series on the
stories of the Bible the psychological
significance of the stories on the Bible
on Tuesday May 16th at the Isabel Bader
Theatre in downtown Toronto I'll put the
address and everything at the bottom of
the video in the description I want to
delve into the biblical stories from a
psychological perspective and I wanted
to do it for a long time and have done
it in part in my maps of meaning series
but the biblical stories are are what
they're canonical in relationship to the
rest of our culture it's very difficult
to understand Western civilization
itself unless you're grounded in the
biblical stories there there are like a
precondition for knowledge of the
humanities and a knowledge of history
for that matter and so I want to improve
my understanding of them and share what
I'm able to figure out with everybody
that I can and so I wanted to just make
a quick video to let everyone know that
I'm going to run a 12-week series about
two hours lecture per week starting May
16th and running till approximately
mid-august pretty much every week except
a couple where I couldn't get the
theater it's pretty nice theater so that
would be good I'd also like to let
everybody know that the videos will be a
taped thanks to my patreon subscribers
and put on YouTube probably within a
week or two after I initially show them
this is we can get them edited in all of
that
so anyways - still season tickets left
that's the tickets that will allow you
entrance to all of the lectures and
they're individual tickets left for each
left
as well and you can get those at Jordan
B Peterson comm but as I said I'll put
all the instructions and the details in
the description of the video below so
tune in on YouTube if you're inclined to
and if you're in Toronto and you'd like
to see them live then come down and see
them live it should be really
interesting I hope that's the plan
anyway so thanks a lot and hopefully
we'll see you there otherwise well
you'll see them on YouTube and that's
good too thanks a lot bye-bye